this morning there are celebrations in
the streets of Harare the capital of
Zimbabwe residents are hoping this
week's house arrest by the country's
military of longtime President Robert
Mugabe will lead to his ouster and end
decades of political repression and
economic failure Debora patta is
following develops developments from
Johannesburg South Africa Debora good
morning good morning the military
takeover of Zimbabwe has plunged the
country into unchartered territory while
the Army has seized power President
Robert Mugabe is refusing to accede to
their demands to step down tens of
thousands of Zimbabweans took to the
streets calling for Mugabe's resignation
for the first time in nearly four
decades they're hopeful they are
witnessing the dying days of his power
but Mugabe who is world Zimbabwe by fear
for 37 years is not going easily he may
be under house arrest but he's been seen
in public twice since tanks rolled into
the capital of Harare here he was
photographed meeting Zimbabwean generals
and regional officials for talks to
negotiate the terms of his removal from
office 93 years old and in failing
health he is regarded by his critics as
a brutal tyrant who ran the country into
the ground but it was his insistence on
pushing his controversial wife Grace
Mugabe as his successor that was
ultimately his undoing the military and
the ruling Zanu PF party however appear
determined to force Mugabe out by the
end of this weekend exactly how that
will happen is unclear
Anthony Debora patta in Johannesburg
thanks